hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to let's play alone oh my
god I am NOT pointing in the right way
oh I got I'm not gonna be looking like
this am i I just adjust it adjust there
we go okay we got it better now ah yeah
wires wires everywhere but anyway you
guys were saying or no
markiplier you're far too much of a baby
to play another one of these
well I proved you guys wrong and I am
now in another oculus rift horror game
called
alone and in alone we are going to be in
a house apparently I don't know much
about this but even some of my
moderators to tell me that I needed to
play it so press Start okay oh wait a
minute oh I'm actually oh wait a minute
holy crap I'm actually I'm actually
sitting oh that's so cool I'm playing a
game in a game it's game ception on here
oh no I didn't get a chance to read that
hey wait wait can I wait can i oh excuse
you excuse you are you quite done over
there excuse Dale are you done
Oh Oh mr. shade are you done are you
quite done
yeah not scary alright so anyway this is
so weird we're literally playing a game
inside of a game and because it's a game
in the game that game inside this game
is oh my god I've gone cross-eyed but
you guys can't see that cuz I'm in the
oculus rift okay so anyway we're going
to okay that's that's another note I am
definitely not gonna try to break it
I've had to lock the main gate to
prevent it from banging around during
the windy nights I left a spare key near
the groundskeepers shed man I heard that
was that in my real life or was that in
yours or was it in the game I don't know
what's real anymore this is so weird
okay so anyway I hear that it's so weird
weird this is really weird I'm
uncomfortable is I got bolt colors oh is
this the key the key that I need this is
this is very strange I'm simulating
myself sitting inside of my house and
okay tree okay I got in there's some red
goop on the floor strawberry jam in the
shape of a giant dingdong maybe no okay
the old house groaned and seemed to be
in a constant oh you're talking about
this house ain't John oh you're talking
about the house that I'm currently in
ain't cha uh settling these old houses
are sure are noisy
well isn't that oddly relevant what's
gonna do to me I've actually gotten
actually quite curious what are you
gonna do to me this is so weird
I play good game but I also have to
worry about what's going on in here oh
my god this is still weird oh my god
don't you be [ __ ] with me hello
what's with the strawberry blood jam all
over the floor caught a glimpse of
someone out in the woods possibly a
groundskeeper who who Jojo whatever
I don't see anyone oh I got the heebie
jeebies like I said before the oculus
rift is surprisingly immersive even
though it's low resolution it's still
then I heard it know pretty terrible
script of the forest
you mean this forest okay already
yeah do not want any oh my god
the more I play the app more I actually
feel like I'm in this room here what the
hell I couldn't fall asleep last night
kept hearing weird noises in the Attic
like someone dragging
oh [ __ ] you who did that who did that oh
no it's happening it's the thing that
it's saying it is only so cool but so
creepy it's cool repeat it's cruel P oh
boy
I don't like down here nothing
absolutely dick dude Lee I hear that
good good oh the attic door was firmly
shut almost as something was placed on
top of it I'll have to find another way
in oh wait what the attic seem to have
opened up wait is the Attic are you
talking about this attic in here
oh I don't want any I don't want any I
don't want any whenever I'm in the
nursery I swear I can hear the voices of
small children Georgia [ __ ] up
around me you
Oh God Evan no God ablet dammit found a
book in the library today I dare not
describe how it is round or the other
words contained how it is bound are some
of these words are hard to read when I'm
talking cuz my voice shakes it a bit I
just got that deep Rumble in my voice oh
my god okay sleeping has become a rough
term for laying awake at night the fear
and suspicion of being watched is
overwhelming
oh no oh no oh oh ah
oh no oh no oh no oh no oh no no I don't
want to read any more notes I don't want
to play Oh No
Doh doh-doh no no no I tried to keep the
camera steady I know guys
no another I saw that
oh that was my shadow nevermind what is
that I heard that that was in my
apartment that was real whose every
who's that hey what is this what are you
doing
then I found him the groundskeeper his
body was a mangled mess and it looked
like his inside had been meticulously
removed hose it I don't know what's real
and what's fake
it it's crucial I place an aspir root in
the pentagram and mark the floor with
appropriate runes only then will the
exorcism be successful what oh my god I
I got a I got a stop and say it's
becoming very hard to differentiate
because I'm playing a game in a game but
it's seeming natural to play that game
in a game and often forget that I look
around and I'm in a house but then I
remember that that house is in a game my
brain is gonna explode this is so weird
I never imagined that I could do
anything like this
oh I hear the creaking but I don't know
if it's in this house in the game or in
this house in the semi game blue bubble
devil she Baba
goodbye okay the hell is that what is
that but what is that whoa
it is sploded why hi oh hi what uh I
couldn't have been more wrong the
exorcism was worthless
stay away get out must get out what I
mean here you mean in here oh not again
oh not again oh my god yo I don't want
any I don't want any you go to you go to
hell if you die you go to hell
excuse you oh not welcome oh hey
but no no no oh you take another step
towards me whatever the hell you are but
no no hello
ah oh I guess I'm done huh oh my god no
so cool
it's still weird it was so cool it's so
weird oh my god that was like the
coolest thing ever I mean it's pretty
creepy but I mean it wasn't like
absolutely awfully scary like a dread
hall's was but I mean that was I was
more marveling at the fact that how cool
that was it wasn't legitimate it was
legit like superdude sorry I'm moving
this all around I'm gonna set this down
so it doesn't shake anymore but I
probably done with that I'm gonna move
that game out of there oh my god that
was so cool it was so cool oh it was so
cool I literally could not tell what was
real anymore and the fact that I heard a
noise I don't even know if that was in
my apartment but I thought for sure it
was but I have no idea this was like the
coolest thing ever oh my god
no like ah it was inception it was
literally in sunshine I was playing a
game in a game in real life and it was
so weird I had to catch myself because I
was literally blurring the lines between
like what was real and what was in the
game and what was in the game game real
world oh my god if you have an oculus
rift play that is so cool so cool oh I
got you got a play anyway that was
amazing oh thank you okay anyway I'm
done screaming my head off about it cuz
it was so cool it was so cool anyway
okay dude that was like the cool thing
that was the coolest thing ever okay I'm
done I'm done
ah okay thank you all so much for
watching click the annotation to war
videos and I'm done
I will see you
huh
ah
No
Oh
good home
the door the door is no longer there ah